I was shocked that this early in the
process you would let your parents near
your show I've never let my parents near
my show and actually for 20 years
whenever we had a skit that involved my
mom we would hire an actress
each time a different actress so my mom
has been played by hundreds of different
women who looked nothing like what and
she's always at home like well back my
mom sat right there and literally was
going like this to me well you swear
constantly
hey I didn't realize that was you know I
I come off a different generation we
don't use those words you know we
couldn't we here was a war on we had to
fight you do first of all what war and
second why would a war prevent anyone
from swear by the time I'm gonna do yeah
we got to stop Hitler there's no time
for these words two three letter words
no four there's no time see we've got to
get going yeah I wouldn't bring it up
because I don't want to what is it girl
what is it I'm like released realistic
back in the history and then this is
like what this is romaine lettuce right
here
look at that that's romaine lettuce I
mean it was my set and I'm not I like
you too I do I really do like your said
I'm this is what I do I'm like ripples
I love this this is the this is the
Amish r2d2 here our fool
Amish lightsabers are just brooms yeah
they're just great they have no harm
says nothing they can accomplish
obi-wan exactly the same except it's a
piece the same multi ones the same he's
the same guy he's just grumpy